I am back and I'm live-streaming from a
hotel actually Hotel Wi-Fi has been
pretty good so far so hopefully it stays
that way my ping is just over a hundred
I'm making tea I don't know if the the
noise of the tea is picking up but it's
being pretty loud a hotel coffee and tea
maker anyway uh this is not gonna be a
long stream unless it turns into a long
stream I've said that before and I'll
I'll I'll say this is gonna be like half
hour and then it ends up being multiple
hours but I I do want to get sleep
tonight so I'll take challenges if
anyone wants to play me hello Chris
first one in the chat I have one pending
challenge
hello cool guy good to see you I have a
casual unlimited challenge I don't I
don't take correspondence chess
unfortunately leather pet if you're
watching I will play you in in normal
chess but not correspondence let's play
cool guy and let's get some tea what
time is it where I am 9:20 p.m. let's
play g6 I'll be right back
Knight c3 usually white will play c4 or
e for nice III trying to remember if
I've seen this exact position and I'm
wondering if there's any way I could
perhaps deviate from main lines I'm
gonna play d5 I think d5 is reasonable
to convert to a Queen's pawn opening
where the knight is sometimes misplaced
on c3 Bishop d2 he wants to take back
maybe that was a mouse slip I didn't go
and cool guy it gave me extra time well
that's nice so I can talk to the chat oh
let's just do this Bishop g7 if he plays
Knight d5 I'll probably have to play
Knight a6 and that will be okay also I
forgot um I forget to mention the chest
I'll go work in the title no I did I
updated the title updates okay
I was so indecisive with a title like I
I probably came up with like three or
four different names until I realized it
was September first so happy September
everyone and hello to cyber warfare so
I'm just completing development I would
like to get the bishop pair with Knight
h5 and that allows Bishop g5 gonna play
a six a six feel slow but I want to play
c5 and I don't want to worry about
Knight to Knight to b5 which is annoying
in many cases I might also want to play
b5 Camel Clutch er yeah I saw you also I
didn't realize like you have a name like
a real name until I saw like your name
on on the pairing sheets because I've
seen your picture before but I didn't
realize you have a name are you are you
related to weight first of all where are
you from and are you related to the
other person in our section with the
same last name because I'm curious
watching my matches against naka
oh that match which I suppressed from my
memory until just now you reminded me
that was a devastating match
can i play b4 b4 94 trade stuff I got
the bishop here let's do it ah okay
and you both stream rights I was trying
to like make the connection but you're
from Colorado interesting I met some
people from Colorado just a few days ago
when I was in st. Louis they run a club
chess which I've heard I've heard
interesting things about but I'm
wondering if wondering if it's worth
like going to Colorado to check out
Manos wants to play me - this is not
going to be a long stream but if you
want to play me send me a challenge
let's take on e4 and then stuff will get
traded I'll probably end up playing rook
a seven to play Bishop e7 pre moving
that wasn't necessary but okay Bishop e7
a double fianchetto
can't complain I'm not up any material
yet but I like the position let's play a
five a five has a very sneaky tactical
threat so we'll see if he sees it
ah I don't know if you saw it but see
three does handle it
I wanted to play Bishop a6 now if you
play c4 I can't on passant
so that's unfortunate I could take I
could play c5 there's a pin c5 looks
very reasonable hey thanks for the auto
host full-circle chess I don't think
I've seen that name before
probably another streamer to check him
out my second game my second game was
wild it was a London line it was my
opponent went like all out for this King
side attack I'm finding all these
sacrifices I was this close to
blundering I almost allowed him to take
on g6 and just I could have like lost a
piece or a pawn or something hello to PS
b25
hello ref Raqqah I am probably going to
make an effort to do more morning
streams rather than evening streams
because I've realized when I stream in
the morning the Europeans are awake when
I stream at this time they're all
sleeping but at least it's a manageable
crowd now maem maem Lanson i will try
and keep up the good work
whoa this looks like drops
everything's on dark squares I would
like to jump him
if this word your office I would have to
take a piece anyway uh Bishop a6 c4 so
that's the forcing line that I couldn't
win the pawn humans this pawn I take
back looks like a free pawn bishop a6 my
knight will come to c6 the original
intention was to win the exchange but
now I think I'm getting away with
winning actually winning a very
important center pond and when night
comes to c6 it just defends everything
and then he five will happen
Israelis are awake what time is it in
Israel hey J with a tier 1 sub thanks
Jay Australians are awake too I guess
ok I was threatening Bishop takes e4 but
now this rook is defended so let's play
this I defend this system this and I
prepare this the night is so useful on
c6 5:30 a.m.
how are you awake I guess some people
are morning people
or you're just like a really like night
person like staying up until 5:30 a.m.
that's crazy okay it's normal time in
Australia it's tomorrow in Australia
what to do
'if I've loses upon or does it there's
some very interesting trick with E 5
which I kinda just want to go for and
see what happens yeah let's play e5
I'm Tanner in person I'm Tanner in
person wait I was thinking there there's
a chess player named his last name is
Tanner that really confused me I've been
spending most of the time inside oh I
think he's gonna fall for the trick I
don't know if this is a trick though I
think it's a trick
the point is a rooks are becoming
disconnected so now I'll have Bishop
takes c4 I think this is working trying
to remember the last time I was outside
for more than 10 minutes that's a really
sad thoughts I played tennis last week
with mvl and Kasim jonov and korilla was
a pretty high rated tennis match do you
subscribers play first um sure if you're
a subscriber let me know your me chest
username and maybe I'll accept you first
I have one pending challenge though no I
have seven I thought it said one oh
maybe the seven looks like a one no I
think I'm not actually ten it's just
like the lighting when the light is dim
then just everything gets darker that's
how light works right
so yeah this is um this is a nifty
little trick queen bee one I think is
only moved to stay alive and now wait
nothing happened we just traded stuff
I'm still up a pond but I didn't with
anything more I would have liked to win
something more I could take on a one I
could play Queen eight could play rookie
seven I could play Bishop d3 but then he
just moves his Queen somewhere
oh my bishop is hanging to keep that in
mind so come on move like queynte just
loses a bishop let's just take on anyone
and save the bishop Queen c7 looks
reasonable ah davier their ultra I
played aviator before did he challenged
me to Ultra bullets
ah he's challenging me to blitz once a
longer match interesting okay so I'm
still up a pawn let's play this I'm
trying to induce him to capture on e6
what's going on for this stream the
stream were just celebrating the 1st of
September nothing else to celebrate I'm
accepting challenges someone convinced
me to accept subscriber challenges first
and thanks to the follow call me Craig
thank you spelled Craig wrong anyway
let's control the C file I'm setting up
yet another trap actually maybe I'm not
or maybe I am if he's watching the
stream which he might be ok he saw the
truth if he were to take on d4 I would
take on e5 back rank matrix so let's
continue setting up traps Bishop Bishop
h3 I don't think accomplishes too much
maybe just t3 rook Tiki 6 could be
strong at some points Queen d6 is
probably a safe move
Luke bb9 yeah you can get a game if I'm
awake long enough to play you eventually
Oh Craig is your actual name interesting
high UV thanks for the follow I haven't
really thanked people for follows in a
while but I appreciate the new followers
someone messaged me right before I
started this dream and he said he checks
my twitch like a few times each day and
he's disappointed because I'm I'm either
offline or I'm hosting people which was
kind of sad but if you want to be
notified when I stream and you have to
follow me and then turn on notifications
you can turn on email notifications or
or through the app you just get mobile
notifications so now there's a lot of
focus on this pawn on d3 I could either
defend the pawn with some move like this
or this or I can go for tricks I would
rather go for tricks because those light
squares are a weak g2
okay so this is my trick the back rank
mates coming up okay yeah
threatening made in one if you were to
take the rook see one yeah so that game
I mean cool guy you played better than a
lot of our previous games I can
definitely see like a jump and
improvement between the way you played
today in the way I played you
what like a couple months ago this game
it was just a matter just a matter of
setting up some tricks the first trick
the first trick was a five threatening
Bishop a six and then the last trick of
the game or way no what was the next
trick bathroom is making weird noises
this is a cool trick with Bishop takes
c4 just traded stuff and then of course
the last trick okay someone wrote an
essay
that's the name of the famous king who
talked to animals I did not know that
but now I know that I sometimes talk to
animals mainly my dog but I mean he
doesn't really talk back okay so who is
a person I think it was Dave either who
convinced me we're playing day viateur
this will be quick it's a blitz game
Dave either has a plus score against me
because he's beating me an ultra bullets
or hyper bullet but time for a revenge
I'm a Petrov I've realized like this is
probably the most aggressive blitz
opening against efore I wonder if I
played this against him before maybe
it's possible h3 is a decent move h3 can
I take on f2 let's have fun take on f2
going for some kill there's some lines
where I could draw but I don't want a
draw I want to win Nigeria stops Bishop
g4 unfortunately that's a key idea in
many of these lines okay let's go for
this
oh my Knights not getting trapped
because if he want went back to g1 I
would have my cheery now the question is
do I play Queen g5 or take the rook
first
[Music]
I'm so conflicted let's play Queen g5 I
just see want to see where he puts his
King there's a king c3 then I should be
happy okay I'm happy but why am i happy
those kings on c3 I have some funny
perpetual check just check check check
okay I can take the rook whenever I want
he wants a draw I don't want to draw
there there I should probably just take
the rook and like what is this position
black is up the exchange King's on D to
develop and defend the check my life is
good
maybe this move whew there's some fancy
mate coming up
except it's not mates
I wanted to play 94 in queenside castle
with mates but he would have Bishop to
d3 and that line that would be a really
difficult challenge I was doing these
weird challenges the other day it would
be a hard challenge like castle with
mates oh let's be civilized and castle
sooner rather than later
can I sack take-take-take Bishop f5
looks good I'm winning the Queen at
least and then I'll have at least a few
pieces left to meet him unless he
doesn't take on d3 that I'll have more
pieces
ooh I was gonna take the queen right
away but Bishop d3 is probably slightly
more convincing dead man D M thanks for
the 50 bits before the arrival of toilet
noggin that's very true
that's a free thing oh shoot I forgot to
text toilet noggin he told me to text
him when I stream
oooh this is double check mates a good
game Dave either I actually that I
haven't studied this line like this
exact variation with eighth with h3 I
only found out about this line first of
all I'll go ahead and say it like a few
weeks ago I was under the impression
that h3 is a good move for white to stop
my g4 and I had a student who I showed
this line to and he kind of stumbled
into this he had a game with h3 and he
was the one who showed me like Bishop
take f2 and when I first saw this I just
dismissed it it's just a ridiculous like
this no way this is working but in the
slime like I think black is at least
forcing a draw with some perpetual if
not more it's hard to play for a white
of course if King e1 there's force means
just Queen h4 Queen f2 so I do want to
look at what will happen should I cheat
and turn on sock fish no I should try
and find the best line for whites King
you two can't be a good move because it
loses back material and the knight
survives so it's really a debate between
these three moves this would be a really
funny line this would be even funnier
Queen f6
so it's a double piece sacrifice with a
king landing on e4 and then the question
is does black have enough comments
he's probably the answer is no unless
there's queen f2 Queen f2 could be
really nice because at five is what is
going on my whites probably defending
unless white isn't defending there's
some funny mate oh no that's not a funny
mate it's not even mate I was imagining
King here here here and then mate but
the kings on e4 so if this is this this
this I have to imagine white surviving
somehow also King g1 is at least a draw
because of Queen d4 with Perpetual there
might be more here I'm not sure
let's cheats let's turn on stockfish and
see all the the answer is starting with
this line my guess after king g1 is it's
just a job but we'll see
Queen d4 anyway for black to fly on
Knight f2 is probably the only way to
play on or Knight g3 in this position
but if black plays on then it's it's
just better for whites okay and then if
King tea
Oh King at three best move Wow so this
line with Queen f6 wait what just
happened there I played Queen f6 in the
valuation went from like plus two to
plus one so it's a stronger move than
the computer saw wow so this is actually
almost enough compensation this is one
thing about using the engine like if
you're down to pieces but the computer
is giving plus 4 or plus point for even
plus one there's a lot of compensation
if you think about it
like white has a value of what like six
five five or six points and someone
giving like one points probably because
the Kings on e4
so just castling here castling makes
sense with rookie eights rookie a
there's a may threat of King III there's
at least perpetual okay so it's
something to look into
yeah interesting line to know I'll be
more prepared next time if you're white
in this position good luck there's
there's so many traps there is a strong
line for whites but I will hold off on
saying it because I'm gonna play more
subscribers so or I'll play more people
in general who wanted to play
oh man I'm losing track who is all there
subscriber Luke was it Luke bb-8 and his
name is Luke 7 I'm just gonna take a
gamble here pretty sure Luke bb-8 is
Luke 7 I'll play him Blitz game good
luck Luke I'll play e4 oh we have to
play j2j is a newest subscriber
I instinctively played Knight c3 because
I want a Grand Prix attack Luke you can
listen to the stream if you want but it
might throw you off because I'm I might
try just to mess with you
ooh Bishop g4 there's some weird line
where why can sack the Queen but
probably not here yet idea is to do this
and this and this kind of the standard
Grand Prix attack
Bishop e6 unexpected let's play f5 make
the bishop move again and then continue
developing white actually has a threat
here
d5 unexpected move looks like a free
pawn will he see the threat he saw one
threat I don't think you saw the other
threats the other threat might not be so
strong but I kind of want to do it
anyway
yeah let's do this bishop take f7 de
viateur
you can probably challenge me again and
if I'm around long enough there's a very
slim chance we can play again
get going 495 in Queenie - the trick is
to continually make threats seizing the
initiative
now this is reminding me of the position
that we pretty much just analyzed with
like the queen a king going back and
forth and then it's a case where I have
this move this move and this move I'm
not sure what to play
because I'm looking for mates probably
still takes work
I'd really don't want to give away the
night but I might want to plop the night
into a square like oh I see the mate
okay it's gonna take some work though
I'm gonna start with this and then do
this and so far he's done a decent job
at defending my threats rook g8 is
playable so my idea was to do this and
now his king is in a bit of a quagmire
I'm still not like mating by force so
it's gonna take some more firepower I
just want to get upon to g6 and that
will finish things off so will he stop
it he's doing well with time about equal
time so far
gee sex good move
what to do do I go completely crazy I
probably do I just want to open the H
file that's all I want in life and then
I want to play b3 idea of being
Kettering and just completing
development and also meeting him
oh I could on passant potentially with
mates cyberwarfare
thanks for the two bits I don't think
I've ever on passant it with Chuck made
before this could be a first is it gonna
happen
no he played e6 I really wanted to do
this and then II five and then on
passant
checkmate but with a pop with a pawn on
e6 I can't I can't
on passant anymore that's so depressing
so what do I do with my life
I mean okay there's desert mates
there's made in oh there's so many great
looking there's rook h7 or f6 rook h7 oh
wait no there's just me than two because
e5 f sixes meet that's nice not what I
wanted but it works kind of oh that's
not made into wait Castle and made him
how can i Castle and made him
or her weight it's Luke
okay bear there see how this could even
be possible
okay I'm just going to I don't know
everything's winning let's just do this
no let's do let's do this first triple
pawns just for the aesthetic value maybe
I'll get to castle with check or
something yeah
I'll castle with check it's far less
exciting than castling with meats still
exciting nonetheless oh I didn't see
that move not here to go to e7 well
that's not good
wait that's not good at all I'm gonna
have to work to win this that the Bishop
on f6 yeah I kind of messed up this
position I was so fixated on on Hassan
ting with meat or counseling with meats
just got carried away
so how many pieces I'm down to pieces
but he's down more pieces which are just
out of the game
this could turn into a dirty flag or a
dirty checkmates threating made in three
remain in four one two three it's going
to be mates
in two to four okay
toilet noggin hello good game Luke seven
just to I mean this this is tweet-worthy
jacksie thanks for the sub appreciate
that this is very much tweet-worthy what
could have happened here like if he
plays any other move he could have
played b5 logical move I was really
hoping for Bishop b2 be five on to
pissant checkmates that would be so
sweet I might I might tweet about this
or or make a gift maybe I'll make a gift
I'll see I'll screenshot this for now
okay
a new game there's so many people I
don't know who's like a subscriber Oh
Manas is a subscriber is he playing or
he is he challenging me I don't see him
oh there he is
okay we're playing Manas 10+2 the very
first time I played Manas he beat me so
let's take this seriously I'll play
efore we'll see what he does
no Joe Ches
I know what no joke chest is talking
about he's not joking
those are some of the the meanest
puzzles imaginable and yeah I just I
don't like people who give on Plus on
puzzles where you don't realize on
pissant as possible I'm gonna play
Knight c3 pre-move every third move
while it's too late cuz just move three
what do I play here I don't know what to
play let's play F for some kind of like
Grand Prix type thing it's been a while
since I played this line ecigs let's do
this stick with somewhat traditional
Grand Prix
I remember Manos likes to play quickly
King each one
I know what no joke is talking about
those are clever and all these like
what's it called retrograde analysis
chess puzzles that incorporate that idea
so yeah usually the rule is when you
play Bishop b5 you're accepting the
trade of a bishop for Knights and now
I'll just play d3 I'm already tired it's
been a long day am i I'm having like AI
problems like my I just twitches when I
I think it's when I just don't get sleep
it's not a good thing cool challenge
unless there's a media threats you need
to always play the same piece that your
opponent just played that would be
interesting and how would be really
interesting I might do that next game
actually curious to see how that turns
out should probably stream on YouTube I
haven't I've only done like a couple
YouTube live streams because I don't
know how to set up OBS and YouTube I
just know how the live stream for my
phone with YouTube I'm sure it's not too
hard to figure out okay so we have some
position do I play a four or do I not
play a four let's play a four typical
move
you can't play b5 because the potential
pin hello too messy Marvin good to see
you
you know my my eye is actually twitching
I wasn't making a joke like I'm on
twitch but maybe twitch is what causes
my eye twitch I don't know the best
opening for intermediate players well
what's your rating cuz I don't know what
intermediate means intermediate could be
like 2000 or it could be a thousand I
like the London opening but that's for
all players I also like the opening that
I played two games ago this the Stafford
gambit in the petrov great opening 1700
[Music]
my two favorite openings are London
opening and Grand Prix attack which is
this thing that I'm currently playing
because I think it's very venomous it's
easy to play cos use some clear
strategies going forward in the middle
game Roy Lopes exchange is also an
interesting opening I've been doing some
research in lately how did my first game
to go today
my first game went well I won I don't
think I mentioned this on stream yet but
I'm in the midst of a tournament I had
two relatively long games today toyline
again thanks for the hundred bits both
games lasted ok maybe about two and a
half to three hours but I feel like I've
played decently deadman DM thanks for
the 51 bits starting a war you lost 54
points in state championships most of
the games are completely won sometimes
the hardest thing to do in chess is win
a winning position when I played my
games today and I got winning positions
I forced myself to just just say focused
but then my legs got
impatient and I started walking around
so he castles so it's always a question
how does white fit or initiate
facilitates the attack I mean in some
cases I want to play g4 but I don't have
a light squared Bishop I'm slightly
concerned about this diagonal so let's
play Queen g3 I would like to play Queen
h3 is 'if I've a good idea
mm I don't know for who but maybe maybe
not ie five gives away some squares also
block has a bishop pair so I don't want
to open up the position if it's not
necessary and I forgot Manas has been
studying lately so I have to be careful
of his capabilities his b5 is a good
move thinking about just playing a5 I
think a5 is normal response and keep the
Queen side files closed
if he plays b4 I'm happy to play 92 if
he plays d5 I'm happy to play e5 and if
he plays b5 I'm happy to play f5 so life
is ok best opening for mm rating person
who really likes tactical chess as white
on e4 e5 tactical chess against a 45
there's a few things I can recommend I
mean mm you're at the level where you
have to play something relatively sound
there's a tricky opening that I've been
looking into recently c4 was slightly
unexpected but it's a playable move I'm
gonna play Bishop e3 just complete
developments
what was I saying
Oh II 45 I mean pons eonni is ambitious
I played Bishop b6 here he's building up
some pressure like Bishop e6 probably
doesn't accomplish too much or does it
I have to think
I wanted to fight rook AE one that loses
a five
I think I'm gonna play Bishop b6
because I would like to unless he wants
to play Queen b7 if he wants to play
Queen b7 and what's the point
f5 doesn't really help he 5 gives him
the d5 square
maybe e5 makes sense because I can
follow up with d4 d5 taketake 95 to take
d4 yeah let's do it
it's a move why not
this is rated to have to be careful the
whole idea I just want to focus on the
center and focus on the Kings side and
just make sure he can't break through on
a queen side so let's take and play this
there's light squared Bishop will be
good but nothing that I can't handle and
maybe at some point I want to play i-5
in Bishop h6 just one idea
get quadruple pawns and still win the
game
I did the challenge with triple pawns
other day I have a very hard time
getting triple pawns Luke B that helped
you during the game yeah I'm aware that
some people listen that's okay 5 s f5
work and some move that I would play and
like bullet or faster blitz I think it
works I'm threatening f6 and I'm
threatening Bishop h6 what does he do
you can't really do anything unless you
can do something let's play off 5 + 5 is
usually the move that you'd like to play
at some points in the Grand Prix attack
like when things are optimized this case
Queen and Bishop are ready to strike do
you have any advice playing games with
more than an hour per side well when it
comes to time what toyline again 10,000
bits is this real life I guess it is he
thank you so much toilet Nagin leading
the bit war Wow I was unexpected it's
only September 1st - this was crazy I
don't even know what to say it's a nice
pogchamp what was i saying i was
answering some questions but now I'm
just completely distracted I'm
completely distracted from the game -
like I got distracted from the game and
then I got distracted from answering the
question I'm just so far detach from
this game right now but now I'm
remembering I played that five and
is still good oh yeah when there's more
than an hour on the clock time is is
always a factor like you have to treat
time as an element of the game and when
you have a lot of time to think you kind
of have to find the balance and one of
the best or one of the most important
skills to have when it comes to time
management is the ability to identify
critical moments
so moments which require thinking
essentially like this moment not so
critical right
I'm just friending me what is he gonna
do he's gonna set the exchange okay but
there's moments in the game what uh oh
my gosh this is not real life
deadman GM III I was not expecting dead
man GM to keep up and again I'm it's do
I take the exchange do I continue to
thank the generous people what do i do I
should probably take the rook those dark
squares are so weak though I could play
Knight g5 ig5 looks really attractive
like 95 in Queen h4 it's risky but I
don't know slavery warfare oh my gosh I
I can't focus thank you guys but I have
a game to play because I don't want to
give away my dark squared Bishop and
trade me it's trading the most valuable
piece
toilet noggin is such a legend but okay
I'm gonna take the rook hey muffin
thanks for the sub so much supports it's
only September 1st
- okay let's down on time getting tired
but now I feel energy I'm just I'm
drinking like chamomile tea like this is
this is supposed to be relaxing okay
I'm optimizing my pieces all my pieces
are optimized I just gave him the a5
pawn but I guess there's more focus on
more important areas of the board like
Knight g5 wait do I care about C 295
then II six ideas let's do it this is
gonna get really strange what dead man
DM oh my gosh you guys are ridiculous
this is not real life at least I'm up on
time so if I can continue or if I
continue to get distracted at least I'm
at least I'm saying at least I have time
to burn okay
stay focused deep breath you sixes of
threats and I take a four is the threats
Queen h4 is the threats I'm just going
to keep these arrows here so if I get
distracted again I'll just remember a
great thing about Lee chess but if he
makes a move to the arrows disappear I
guess we'll find out oh they don't
disappear okay so now I take e for is no
longer an option
Queen h4 runs into h6
how many pawns on my down I can barely
count I have not won a single pawn yet
[Music]
so e6 at 6:00 night at 7 what is going
on there wait this is so confusing
b6 f 6 9 f 7
okay time is important I mean II 606
maybe just night back to f3 keep my
night in a reasonable place and then I
want to play d5 at some points okay I
really have to focus this is getting
really sharp I don't have much time I
feel like I should just start with e 6
make him think about playing f6 he's
gonna play off 6 oh no I can't
can I take Queen h4 and no that doesn't
work ideally if he plays f6 I want two
moves just so you got my pawns like this
I'm just scared about his Queen side
pawns I'm not sure should my knight go
to f7 or not because I don't want it to
get stuck so I'm gonna yeah I'm gonna
move it back because I want to play this
and this or just 9 h4 and go after f5 or
go after g6 this is okay this looks
reasonable and there is 2 second
increments so we could get low on time
and still not flag but I'm happy with
this these pawns are so nice I forgot
about that move
maybe I can do this cuz I'm threatening
after ending this if he takes on d5 I
take on f5 also Toyota noggin 1000 two
bits with the salt I can't thank you
guys enough making my month it's only
the first of the month where is my Yeti
blue my Yeti blue is still broken toilet
not gonna actually offer it to [ __ ] me
one for my birthday but okay I have to
focus but I have one that's under
warranty I just have to ship it back in
there they'll send me a new one for free
let's play this oh my gosh ten thousand
more bits from toilet noggin this is
insane
don't play knight c6 96 he takes on d5
wait I I can't focus
cuz there's so many bits the last time
honest beat me he posted on reddit and
like everyone saw I was so embarrassing
let's take on that five ooh
that's probably a really bad move that
was a really bad I'm about to lose this
taketake now I'm on the verge of losing
this cuz h3 maybe h3 I've been in these
situations before like you have to stay
calm and you have to essentially play
objectively way he doesn't take okay I
don't know I hate he didn't queen so now
he's actually giving me some hope and he
could have queen there but maybe he's
just trying to play on time as I'm
holding on to e6 now I want to play rook
e1 I've to play very fast much faster
than I've been playing yeah Fe Queens I
would have played on like down a piece
pawns would have been he would have been
up upon to I really don't want to give
him the joy of beating me though that's
the worst part about this okay if he
moves the bishop I can play e7 then I'm
winning I have to move quick oh he
tricked me I was a dirty move I'm still
alive though I have my e pawn I'll win
c2
ah this is bad again
okay let's defend the last rink
okay he's actually playing very safe
which give me more time to improve we're
probably going to draw but I'm playing
this for a win I'm down two pawns but
his King is a bit exposed I play this
for a win I have to play based on time
hmm this is bad again dead man TM I
can't I can't
I'm sorry I want to thank you but I have
to stay focused three is weak it's also
strong please play rock a seven
please play rook a7 he's playing good
moves
maybe I'll trade Queens mmm this is bad
this is really bad okay we're gonna get
some three-on-two ending see his
technique here as a so draw no this is
winning for him or is it a draw wait
this might be a draw I think this is a
draw
now this is definitely the draw I've
never been so happy to draw - I'll take
a draw if I have a pawn I would try and
flag him but insufficient meeting
material
I'm so happy to survive that I'm also
disappointed that I drew him but some it
was hard to focus
thank you - dead man DM and toilet
noggin not for distracting me but for
just being so generous with your bits
you guys are both legends and flair in
third place in the bit war oh you're new
to chess why is that a draw I'm actually
curious like how many people are
watching that may not have seen this
ending before this is if you're new to
justice is one of the very first things
that you should learn and the way to
learn this is to watch John Bartholomew
King pawn endgame if you google John
Bartholomew King pawn ending or end game
you will find a great video which I will
share in the chat a great video for
beginners anyone new to chess who wants
to learn from the one and only Finn's
team scandi anyway yeah going back in
time - also this this should be winning
some yeah I mean okay - six I want to go
back - yeah this moment I mean he could
Queen I had two seconds left I was gonna
play on by taking and of course I can't
take his back ring mates but I would
play Queen f3 and then I thought there
would be some flights just cuz
I have puns and his bishop still out of
play I was gonna play rook do you want
and just hold on to d5 for dear life was
a three-on-two a force drop now a
three-on-two should be winning like that
how it's winning it's still a bit tricky
maybe let's disable engine analysis for
now yeah this is probably a good endgame
lesson cuz black should yeah black
should take with the pawn ah this end
game yeah so there's there's a known
position where black can can start by
playing this move and then the trick for
black is to walk the King walk the King
basically so it can access f2 and it
kind of comes down to opposition in this
case it shouldn't be too difficult
let's imagine I'm in some money with
1500 bits this was like really
unexpected just so much generosity of
the stream but let me keep going here so
let's say King f3 King ie5 king e - this
is where a black can see the opposition
with Keeney 4 and then white is forced
away if King D - there's simple
breakthrough at 3 and that's easy win so
let's say kini 1 King III King F 1 Kim D
- Kim Ji Won King e2 and now a very
important idea I feel like I've I've
given this position to students my I've
had them play outs from the position
after g3 and they they have sometimes a
hard time getting to this points then
when they get to this point they have a
far hard time finding the next move the
next move is f3 given that after a pawn
to f3 King f2 and it's not stalemate and
it's just me and if you move
and if if kingi one of course there's f2
and promote to ruck so yeah that's it's
one of these things which like there's
certain end games you should just know
this is one of these end games it's just
useful to know but I also wanted to show
a trick I was actually hoping for a line
where he would go for this maneuver
because like this also looks winning
with the keen coming to g3 but white no
weights
Oh white doesn't have a force draw here
if the pawns were shifted up I rank then
it would be a forced 1/4 draw but I mean
g3 is like the usual drawing idea the
black is still winning here because King
h3 and if take then king h2 and black is
winning so Manas yeah study your end
games but what's cool here wait 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 this is really cool because we can
use a seven piece table base from this
position props to leech s4 for
implementing this apparently it took a
lot of computer power to solve for those
of you who are who might not know what
table base is essentially every chess
position with 7 or less pieces on the
board is solved so this position there's
exactly 7 7 pieces
pawns included and we can see that black
actually has a number of winning moves
here g4 is the way to make the quickest
progress and now it will be interesting
to see I'm actually going to turn off
table base for a moment because it will
be interesting to see where he made the
the drawing or the the crucial mistake
and it may have been with King take g4
see I mean
Shh e4 is much easier win hello the
fucsia and think simon cemani for
another hundred bits because i'm not
sure it can black win this in King G 3
King f1 this is what happened
h4 what was I thinking
I think this is just a draw because like
white will always hold on to the pawn
the only way from black to make progress
is to eventually pawn break but then
there's no there's no effective break
through so I'm pretty sure King take g4
is a drawing move yeah it's sad because
King like visually team takes g4 it
looks very strong walking the King to g3
but the only winning move here as we see
in table this is H take g4 so that was
that was enlightening fun game thanks -
it was that worthy enough to post on
reddit very first time I played - the
reddit post got like over a hundred
hundred up votes went slightly viral
mana so you can you can re-watch the
video or we watch the stream after I
finish and judge for yourself if I got
distracted anyway uh I'm gonna play J
cuz he was like the very first
subscriber of this month he's also uh
he's also in Australia I've met J in
person before J is a very first person I
ever met in person through leech s good
luck Jay what do I want to play there's
okay there's no wait I'm gonna do the
challenge that someone recommended I'm
gonna do this the you play the same
piece that your opponent just moved
I'll see that how this goes
d4 okay so pawn I recapture with pawn
okay now I have to move the bishop let's
play Bishop to c5 died already blunder
it's Bishop take f7 to move or no that's
a mainline there's some like crazy line
here
I think 95 is a blunder because then
there's this stuff and then this Queen
h5 hitting the bishop so I'm pretty sure
not h6 is a move which still fulfills
the challenge because it moves the
Knights I'm pretty sure this is still
like mainline if he castles and I can
castle Queen h5 so I have to move the
Queen well let's play Queen e7 defend
these guys he's gonna take on f7 which
winds up on back and okay in cases where
I only have legal moves with other
pieces I have to kind of break the rule
if it's immediate threat but so far I'm
managing like no immediate threat I'm
gonna castle and I think J said he was
gonna mute the stream so I'm sure he's
gonna watch this later and only realized
that what I'm doing so okay we'll see
how this goes
I mean I'm tied down to f7 but it's
defended four times
oh the three check thing was ridiculous
night move well there's an immediate
threat hi I don't think I can defend
against the threat what do I do here oh
I can play Knight g4 lhe Forza nifty
little move idea of Queen to g4 there's
d5 as Bob Ross would say this is a happy
accident and now d5 ooh
bishop okay so now there's an immediate
threats I have to I have to move the
Queen here I could move the knight I'm
not gonna move a bishop I could take on
e4 let's take on e4 it looks like a free
pawn
now I'm threatening another free pawn
soon to be free pawn and I'm defending
my knight oh I forgot about that move
and again it's a it's a media threat how
do I not lose a queen for free g6 is
probably the only move I forgot jeez Jay
is is a reasonable player like 1977 I'm
not dead yet
I'm counter attacking his Queen if he
takes my queen I take his queen now I
can move my queen while still fulfilling
the challenge and not getting mated he's
gonna play rook e1 which is annoying
rook e1 though I can play Knight g5 okay
so now I have to move a knight Knight g5
looks very reasonable cuz I just want to
trade I want to trade everything trade
Queens trade knights and I'm still up
two pawns maybe what I'll do this game
while still fulfilling this challenge of
moving the same pieces that my opponent
is flying I take on f3 I can't move the
Queen so I can either take on a
three-year take the Queen back let's
take the Queen back
there's an additional challenge where I
could try and win this game without
losing a single pawn as I'm already up
to pawns I've I've oh the queen is the
first piece he's captured I was about to
say I haven't lost any other pieces but
now we're trading a bunch that's
annoying
well there's immediate threats I'm kind
of inclined to move my bishop but no
it's um you that's right there's no
reason to lose a rook plate rook up
seven second seiji first time ever
catching the livestream how many of you
are watching where it's your first time
ever catching the livestream okay so he
moves a knight I will I will move my
Knights and capture his Bishop and then
he moved upon so I move upon um if it's
your first time watching I apologize for
taking this game a little not so
seriously but this is okay this is uh
how I enjoy myself I guess whenever he
moves a knight I just have to I can move
any piece I want so that's how it will
work do I play e4 uh yes I play e4 on
occasion he moves upon I also played d4
a lot I play a lot of different openings
and that's another thing I do if people
want to suggest opening recommendations
the cooler first time for you ah so yeah
there's a lot of people who watch later
on youtube do I play e5 there's a line
where a5 b5 and we trade and we trade on
a1 and I take his pawn and then he has
rook a8 and and and
you wins a bishop to keep all of this in
mind there's no oh there's no increment
so wait I have to move a pawn though
let's play beef five free up the square
for the bishop move here oh I forgot he
can fork me okay I'm still gonna try and
follow the thing oh my gosh
wait oh no I didn't mean to pre move
that okay I'm not gonna follow the rule
anymore I'm just gonna hold on for dear
life
cuz I'm counting the exchange and I'm
down on time severely oh that was such a
good move he's gonna beat me unless I
can survive no well good thing that was
casual I failed in all regards I lost
the game I stopped paying attention to
the challenges I lost a lot of pawns
good game Jay Congrats to Jay Jay is
also waited just a stream know this
other guy from Australia who streams
main-sequence almost got them confused
good game Jay I was really sad
the ending was really interesting like
this position though what was going on
here Jay has beaten me the last of the
last two times or the last three no the
last two times
ah alas game he played was Fischer
random oh that was a correspondence game
I forgot to move and losing to
subscribers is a good business
philosophy I did not intend to lose but
I've just forgot about the time
situation it's getting late I have a
tournament game starting in just over 11
hours maybe one more game
it was my serie give me a random number
between 1 and 17 ok well oh now I have
18 challenges so we'll count backwards
from 18 18 17 this is it's really late
17 16 15 okay this is crazy house good
luck to my opponents what tournament am
i playing it I'm playing the Illinois
open I play crazy house let's play
Knight f6 in d5 and take okay so this is
some opening I guess for those of you
who haven't seen crazy house before
welcome to crazy house essentially the
rule is any piece you capture it turns
into a piece of your own that you can
place on the board any time you want as
its own move so I'm gonna place a pawn
on f4 cuz why not attack the knight
first time catching a live stream
there's a lot of you people I almost
never play crazy house so this is kind
of new I have played a decent amount of
bughouse in recent times I mean last
week I was playing bug house with
Aronian and mvl and there they're pretty
good
let's play Bishop conflicted here let's
develop you know he wants to put upon
enough to though which is a problem so
let's play this can you recommend a
black opening for you what's your rating
and what's your style let me ask you
that
Charles Lucas if I haven't answered
everyone's questions I'm sorry it's hard
to keep up with the chat
Scandinavian is not a bad opening if you
want to learn the Scandinavian just
watch John Bartholomew play chess he's
good at that opening tempted to take on
a ch3 place a pawn I don't know this
game is so confusing I'm just gonna
develop opening principles thanks Nakul
ER Trey she ate the luck wishes h2 what
a move do I even do here I could take
them no let's play 94 Knights I think
are more valuable than crazy house also
Jay a good game and goodbye I'll see you
in the future let's play Bishop here
just want a battery this isn't an
aggravated battery it's just a battery I
can take this for I don't even know what
I'm doing
it's really late this is probably my
last game unfortunately
I just want to meet him
it's a decent player I just lose a piece
no mine my queen defends my knight so
this is just a trade let's stick with
the pawn he has no more pieces to place
that's a good sign
can I take and then take and then take
and then just meet him let's try that I
feel like I'll run out of fuel though
mmm I'm not sure let's take the bishop
first we'll see if he's brave enough to
take the Queen he's an operative enough
so now I can do this this was gonna be
fun oh he didn't want to take the Queen
I think I would have had forced mates
with bishop here a king here a pawn here
King here at night f2 mates this game
gets very tactical wait okay there's
increment that's good increment is all I
need so let's trade
another thing about this game is
material is less relevant it's a lot
more about initiative also time is
important to do I take let's do this
keeps attacking me it's hide away what
is going on I went from playing very
aggressively to oh I have three seconds
left there's only a one second
increments so I do have to play much
much quicker
no I didn't want to put upon any seven I
wanted to take the night okay this is
bad now this is really bad
oh my gosh
he's crushing me now he is a queen and a
bishop in hand this is really bad I'm
still kind of alive still three seconds
left
wait I'm I'm surviving this I think I
have a lot of pieces how am i alive here
oh he has made in one don't see it
please don't see it
my PA was made to take precautions yeah
rook da mate was coming next that was
really difficult let's not play more
crazy house donut number one of crazy
house don't accept crazy-ass challenges
I like that apply that rule for the
future
so I've lost two in a row and I drew -
it's been a bad performance I try and
get one more game
let's get one more game I want to play
the quickest the quickest time control 3
plus 2 perfect playing a 9:31 good luck
moshi-moshi I don't think I've ever
played someone below a thousand sure I
have but let's end this on a good note
I'll manage my time I'll say
aggressively Brandon Ken thanks for the
comments let's play this Budapest I did
give a lecture on the Budapest for st.
Louis Chess Club a couple years ago III
had some move slightly passive I'll take
and go for d5 I mean I think 1500 is the
average rating on the chest because
everyone starts at 1500 so 931 I mean
it's 600 points below average it's
pretty low but there has to be someone I
mean he's playing a good game so far
actually despite not really knowing the
opening lets was Castle toilet noggin is
tired I'm tired
please take this pawn please yes
I just wanted the this open open file
before he can castle and now he's lost
casting rights
well let's just develop the problem with
not castling and playing King f1 is the
fact that this rook has a very hard time
getting into the game so that should
make make things good for black I just
want to take and win the pawn and be
happy toilet noggin is bitter also
that's a free night
you can't win everything that's what
I've learned
life is tough okay now the goal is to do
this the first the first seven to eight
moves of the scheme basically until King
f1 he played very strong or he played he
played very reasonably far above nine
hundred also mate next move yeah there
is one instructive moment I think this
is a very instructive moment this
situation can come from a lot of
different openings where if your
opponent is not castled and you are
castled in the files open you would like
to create a battery on the the open
e-file with rook e8 I'm Bishop e2 is a
more natural move and then Queen e7 with
the idea that White's King has now tied
down to the bishop now actually I don't
know how powerful it is in this case
because he has Knight c3 and I'm still a
bit underdeveloped so actually this
would be fine for whites there are some
cases where if I could build up more
initiative maybe it could be even
stronger
anyway I'm tired it's been this was a
longer extreme than I intended I was
only intending to play like a few games
and then turned into a lot but again
thank you so much to everyone who
subscribed who followed who watched the
first time and thank you to toilet
noggin for 30 1105 bits and to Dedmon DM
for one more bit than toilet noggin I've
never seen anything like that but I
appreciate it
this encourages me to stream more but
I'm in the midst of a tournament so I
have to prioritize this tournament
taking place I played two tournament
games today I'm play two tomorrow I
played two Monday and then I'll be a
free person
toriel dogged with two bits I think
that's a good way to end things so yeah
I will be back in the future um but
before I go oh my gosh dead man GM with
another that wasn't bits before I go I
want to UM I want to give a shout-out to
wait if Tata is still streaming I'm
reading her but she's not still
streaming oh she's not streaming okay
I'm giving a shout-out to where's my I
don't even know her username Wow
toilet noggin also with a thousand bits
I'm trying to find this person's twitch
username I just want to send everyone
over to her
are you guys serious
I'm trying to find the username but
maybe I should keep stalling
no I if you guys have heard of
Alexandria Lopez she's doing a 24 hour
stream and what I would like people to
do is join the raid if you're watching
on the leech has embedded thing you have
to you have to go to like my twitch page
and then just be part of the raid this
is really confusing why am I not seeing
her oh here she is
is she not streaming chess she better be
streaming chess chess and more okay well
she's a chess player I'm reading her
thanks again guys for being so curious
where did like what do they do with the
chat there's a chat okay raid Alexandra
and I'm really sorry she's not even in
streaming chess if you want to watch
chess watch - he has like 5 viewers
right now he's he's the one who drew me
but we're reading Alexandra who's
playing fortnight's I've never raided a
fortnight player but ok I'm taking off